for the solomons the war in ukraine hits
close to home they did missionary work
there for five years their youngest
child lived there longer than here
she wakes up every morning and she goes
our friend's still alive and i never
thought i'd have to deal with that as a
parent although a bit older their sons
have concerns too
our 12 year old he has big questions he
wants to know why humanity
is kind of acting this way
what is the purpose of it
registered psychologist dr brent
mcdonald says war is a challenging thing
for anyone let alone children to
understand what i really encourage
parents to do is first of all check in
with your kids to see what they do know
and what their what their understanding
of what's happening is
because there's probably going to be a
lot of misconceptions
he says kids need to feel safe he
suggests using a map to show where
russia ukraine and canada are in
relation to one another but pretending
this war isn't happening is
counterproductive ignoring what's
happening around us is
i would argue in pretty much any
situation not effective particularly for
kids because that becomes a habit
children are still hearing about what's
going on be it online or in school
certainly this is being talked about in
our classrooms and it's being talked
about in a way
that is respectful certainly and isn't
keeping in mind that this this could
could be trauma inducing for some of our
students mcdonald encourages focusing on
positives like humanitarian efforts it
doesn't mean we have to be into the
the gory details of everything but we
can give them the information that they
that they want to see that they want to
hear
at their level
the solomons are just trying to do their
best
talking with them it's been very
difficult
we try to be realistic
but we also try to help them to
understand
what
is going on
sarah ryan global news